[Musica]
grazie grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
Intanto volevo ringraziare l'università
la magnifica rettore i docenti ma
soprattutto le ragazze e i ragazzi di
questa straordinaria università che fa i
numeri nel mondo ma oggi siamo chiamati
sono stato chiamato a parlare di cross
ma diciamo di questa
contaminazione una contaminazione prima
il magnifico rettore la magnifica
rettore ha parlato proprio di
contaminazione
io oggi voglio Ecco inquadrare del
perché la situazione internazionale il
contesto internazionale ci porta a
rimettere in discussione le nostre
certezze tutto quello che noi oggi
abbiamo come pilastri
fondamentali sono rimessi in discussione
dalla pandemia che c'è stata che ha
coinvolto tutto il mondo da questa
guerra questa guerra odiosa che ha
rimesso in discussione gli equilibri
anche mondiali gli equilibri di
Geopolitica tra i grandi continenti
addirittura le nazioni unite addirittura
la nato sono rimesse in discussione come
punto di riferimento della comunità
internazionale Ma come voi sapete questi
pilastri di certezze possono essere
rinegoziati rimodulati
e noi oggi vi voglio parlare in questo
momento di un sogno
Che cos'è un sogno Noi siamo fatti siamo
parte integrante del nostro sogno della
nostra idea e tutti i giorni dobbiamo
cercare una strada che ci porti in
qualche modo a vedere il nostro attuale
Orizzonte e andare oltre questo
Orizzonte questo Orizzonte tutti i
giorni per cercare nuove forme nuove
nuove conoscenze nuove tecnologie per
andare ancora oltre a nuovi obiettivi
per cercare nuovi appunto orizzonti
perché questi nuovi orizzonti ci fanno
crescere questo il sogno e tutto questo
modo di essere parte di questo sogno ha
fatto nascere in Italia il microcredito
il microcredito nasce per un'intuizione
almeno la sua conoscenza
un'intuizione del premio Nobel per la
pace i Invece quando
nell'altro secolo nel precedente secolo
negli anni 70
sostanzialmente il premio Nobel e gli
humus lanciò Il microcredito e quindi
divenne una conoscenza mondiale
il segretario delle Nazioni Unite con
affianco lanciò questo appello subito
dopo e l'Italia fu il primo paese a
raccogliere questo appello per l'anno
internazionale del microcredito come
strumento di lotta alla povertà e
l'escursione finanziaria addirittura
come strumento di lotta all'estrema
povertà l'Italia fu il primo paese
riuscì a creare un organismo pubblico
perché il microcredito Oggi dobbiamo
capire non è la stessa cosa del piccolo
prestito che fanno bene le banche il
piccolo prestito è un piccolo prestito
che le banche fanno quando c'è la
garanzia di mamma papà quando c'è
comunque una garanzia generale per fare
un'impresa
la mano pubblica interviene tramite noi
perché abbiamo intuito che quella fascia
di povertà di esclusione finanziaria era
e è un problema per il nostro paese per
la comunità internazionale e siamo stati
i primi a creare una struttura pubblica
che desse un altro opportunità ai
giovani alle startup a tutti coloro che
volevano creare un'azienda ma non avendo
garanzie reali
nel garanzie ovviamente personali non
potevano farla perché il sistema
bancario non è attrezzato a fare questo
tipo di interventi Allora siamo
intervenuti siamo intervenuti noi della
microfinanza del microcredito
raccogliendo quell'appello delle Nazioni
Unite e oggi sono nate in Italia primi
al mondo siamo sono nate oltre 20.000
nuove aziende negli ultimi anni dalla
fascia dell'esplosione finanziaria che
oggi sono aziende che lavorano
sono aziende che comunque assumono altre
persone non sono un costo per lo Stato
perché il microcredito non è beneficenza
è un'azione è una best pratiche che oggi
ci riconoscono anche a livello europeo
quindi se noi partiamo da questo
concetto Nazioni Unite ionus Nazioni
Unite Italia Oggi facciamo capaci di
building anche a livello internazionale
perché questo modello italiano la via
italiana al microcredito ci ha
consentito di soddisfare i bisogni senza
alimentare i desideri
Perché molti parlano di Finanza etica
molti parlano di
comunque di dare di Cooperazione di dare
sostegno di dare una mano ma pochi
effettivamente percorrono quell'ultimo
miglio che divide il bisogno dalla sua
soddisfazione Ecco noi la microfinanza
ha contaminato tutto questo mondo ha
contaminato in termini positivi il
territorio Siamo ripartiti dal
territorio no dalle grandi strategie
perché il territorio è il faro delle
nostre
della nostra visione quindi il sogno del
microcredito oggi È una realtà e se
vogliamo cercare Nuovi Orizzonti la
microfinanza è il punto di riferimento
dell'economia sociale di mercato perché
prima vi ho parlato dello scenario
internazionale
perché lo scenario internazionale è
animato da un grande vero bipolarismo
non quello politico che oggi ascoltiamo
centrodestra centro-sinistra al centro
non si sa bene Di quale di quale cose
parliamo ma il vero bipolarismo è il
confronto quotidiano tra l'economia
sociale di mercato e l'automatismo del
mercato
l'automatismo del mercato ha come
obiettivo il profitto
l'economia sociale cioè tutti noi
abbiamo come obiettivo la soddisfazione
dei bisogni della persona della persona
umana se noi capiamo questo che
l'obiettivo di ogni politica di ogni
azione economica sociale culturale
finanziaria bancaria e la soddisfazione
dei bisogni della persona allora quando
si crea utilità Questa può essere
rivestita Ma attenzione gli amici del
Mercato dell'automatismo del mercato non
sono nostri nemici
non sono nostri nemici perché
Il sistema funziona Se c'è un equilibrio
tra l'automatismo del mercato e la
politica economica quindi l'economia
sociale Ma chi è che deve garantire
questo equilibrio questo equilibrio Lo
deve garantire la politica e la politica
non deve entrare in campo come Player in
queste fasi di governo economico perché
se tifa per uno per gli altri c'è lo
squilibrio del sistema Allora le cose
non funzionano perché la politica deve
essere una politica ad alta intensità
Oggi viviamo in una politica bassa
intensità perché in molte occasioni
Entra in campo a favore degli Uni e per
gli altri e quindi c'è un dislivello e
quindi ci sono sacche di povertà ci sono
eccessivamente ecceli di ricchezza
eccessi di ricchezza e ci sono tutte
quelle cose che oggi Noi viviamo allora
un ente regolatore anche nel settore
della
contaminazione finanziaria positiva e
quindi della microfinanza oggi ci ha
consentito anche di intercettare tutte
quelle nuove generazioni le generazioni
ovviamente
che noi amiamo definire la generazione z
i nativi digitali
che sono nati in un periodo particolare
anche di grande crisi non siamo più
abituati al face to face ma oggi
dobbiamo interagire anche con la persona
quindi l'ente nazionale del microcredito
il microcredito la microfinanza Italiana
oggi nel mondo è considerata uno
strumento un conduttore sano di
relazioni e di possibilità anche per I
need che è un'altra fascia sulla quale
Nessuno ha mai veramente voluto
intervenire che sono i giovani che ormai
non studiano non lavorano e quindi su
questi noi dobbiamo intervenire stiamo
intervenendo fino a 29 anni pensate
quanti ragazzi che dovrebbero essere la
classe dirigente del futuro che oggi non
sono intercettati e questo modo di
essere
contaminanti positivi No siamo riusciti
a creare anche tra la nuova generazione
Z e giovani nette cosiddetti nette anche
delle Sinergie per portare nuove formule
nuove possibilità e soprattutto nuovi
sogni quindi lotta alla povertà da una
parte
esclusione finanziaria dall'altra sono i
due elementi che ci devono far capire
qual è l'obiettivo politico non è un
obiettivo accademico il nostro perché la
microfinanza è uno strumento potente che
risolve i problemi non alimenta le
speranze ma risolve i problemi qual è
l'obiettivo l'obiettivo politico di
queste operazioni l'obiettivo politico è
quello di togliere dalle fasce della
povertà e dell'esclusione finanziaria
più persone possibili
Questo significa che lo stato Oggi ha un
costo qualsiasi stato quando una persona
è disoccupata Non può accedere al
credito quando un giovane dopo che aver
dopo aver studiato non può dare forza
alle proprie idee e i propri obiettivi
perché non può accedere al credito
e questo rappresenta un grande problema
perché quando va bene quella persona
disoccupata è un costo per i servizi
sociali quando va male è facile
manodopera per la criminalità e pensate
che danno la comunità può avere da
queste da questi problemi invece quando
quella persona riesce a accedere a
credito grazie alla mano pubblica che
non è la mano invisibile di Adam Smith
la mano pubblica interviene non lascia
indietro nessuno quelli che hanno un
business plan sostenibile vengono
sostenuti finanziari e garantiti dallo
Stato che copre l'80% del rischio
e quella persona quella giovane donna o
quel giovane ragazzo che vuole aprire e
vuole dare forza a un proprio sogno una
propria idea diventerà un'azienda non
diventerà manovalanza della criminalità
non diventerà un cliente per i servizi
sociali potrà aprire un'attività potrà
assumere altre persone restituirà quel
credito perché questo è il segreto non
si fa beneficenza si fa Economia sociale
e tutto funziona funziona con la forza
delle idee e quindi quando noi parliamo
di economia sociale di mercato è una
scelta non solo politica ma una scelta
culturale e la forza che noi dobbiamo
mettere in questi progetti e voglio
chiudere
con una battaglia vera che noi dobbiamo
fare a tutte le forme di povertà perché
la diplomazia preventiva deve diventare
una democrazia ad alta intensità che
evita guerre conflitti ma soprattutto le
guerre conflitti si parte alzando la
scolarità alzando la cultura dei popoli
ai quali noi facciamo Cooperazione e su
questo obiettivo voglio chiudere anche
ricordando un presidente amato da molti
americani da tantissimi americani
Kennedy che ricordava se
la ricchezza non dà la felicità
figuriamoci la povertà Grazie
[Applauso]